avec nous ce soir jonathan julien le
ministre de l'énergie et des ressources
naturelles bonsoir monsieur julien oui
bonjour monsieur julien merci d'être
avec nous ce soir pour parler de ce
développement pour le québec c'est quoi
l'intérêt la justification de se lancer
dans le solaire à ce moment ci écrit mes
étudiants vous le savez comme moi le
plan d'approvisionnement guidon québec
était déposée l'automne dernier m'ont
clairement qu'en 2026 au moment où on va
avoir besoin de plus d'énergie et de
puissance le 26e puissance 27 de
l'énergie et on regarde actuellement à
toujours dans l'énergie renouvelable
qu'ont annoncé aujourd'hui à rennes et à
la prairie c'est un laboratoire on parle
de dizaines de mégawatts le mille
résidences mais ça nous permet de venir
tester par rapport aux guérés
d'énergétique du québec par rapport à
notre transport à la distribution
comment on est encore l'énergie solaire
qui effectivement énergies de l'avenir
on voit que le coût du solaire est en
forte réduction de manière exponentielle
et quand on regarde le coût marginal
d'ajouter d'énergie renouvelable au
québec on pense que l'éolien est déjà là
et que le sol est rapidement le voyait
tendre et très concurrentiel aujourd'hui
on a investi 40 millions pour deux
centrales solaires déjà les nouveaux
projets d'hydro-québec guen augmenter le
coût moyen de production en quoi c'est
bénéfique de venir ajouter du solaire
dans notre dans notre portefeuille
énergétique vous pas l'attention ici le
40 millions et points et corporelle la
tarification c'est vraiment dans une
perspective de recherche et de
laboratoires
si on prend par exemple actuellement au
québec quand je me promène partout à
travers à travers le monde
on a un avantage concurrentiel dip est
remarquable 99.4 de l'électricité au
québec c'est énergies renouvelables 90%
c'est de l'hydroélectricité 4% c'est de
leurs liens et 4 points quelques pour
simple dont on ne la batterie avec
l'hydroélectricité à bgc on a un courant
continu avec lequel on peut mettre la
switch à off et cumulé dans nos bassins
non condamnées avec l'énergie
interminables comme les alliés comme le
solaire
ça nous permet d'utiliser cette énergie
leur cas elle est produite quand il fait
soleil quand il vint est autrement on à
la guerre
si avec notre batterie de pouvoir
toujours donner de la puissance donc
puisqu'on à cette réalité là nous on
pense que d'ajouter du solaire rajouter
de l'éolien actuel mali reviennent on le
fait à poux est assis sous probablement
que le prochain contrôle doit être prêt
de 5 sous le coût marginal de cette
énergie la considéra qu'on a des grands
barrages hydroélectriques et moins
dispendieux peut-être que d'autres
ouvrages hydroélectriques
non nous ici au québec on a cet avantage
là c'est pour ça qu'on va voir un
bouquet de sources d'énergie l'éolien le
solaire dont les coûts sont de plus en
plus faible aucune énergie intermittente
mais où on a la richesse de
l'hydroélectricité monsieur julien ce
qu'on a pas vous parler d'intermittents
justement est-ce qu'on n'a pas notre
grand besoin
n'est-il pas surtout de s'occuper de
notre grande puissance énergétique pour
répondre aux périodes de pointe ans
c'est là qu'on a besoin d'énergie le
solaire à 6 heures le soir en hiver ce
sera pas très utile quand même
effectivement c'est dire que même pour
le salaire ici dans le laboratoire
on voit également intégrer une batterie
de stockage à des sorties justin mapp
pour venir tester quand on peut stocker
de l'énergie intermittents l'énergie
monsieur les ambiances à votre très
rapidement ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui je
prends l'exemple de l'éolien on a
négocié des contrats à xiii sous
actuellement on est assis sous à cinq
sous ça va très rapidement se compliquer
avec le soleil s'est positionné
aujourd'hui parce qu'on voit bien la
perspective de 2003 à la fois sur le
coût de production est sur le stockage
potentiel pour nous amener en maintenant
des avantages concurrentiels donc est ce
que vous êtes toujours dans l'esprit de
la politique énergétique qui a été
déposé par le gouvernement couillard
c'est-à-dire d'augmenter de 25% la
production d'énergies renouvelables
d'ici 2030 est ce que c'est toujours
votre engagement à vous ça c'est un non
on continue avec la politique
énergétique
ok on nous le renvoyer à un appel
d'offres on travaille déjà avec hydro
québec pour renouveler les contrats des
aliens pour aller sur de nouveaux appels
d'offres d'énergie et ça sort toujours
d'énergies renouvelables est-ce qu'on va
pas se retrouver avec des semaines on a
déjà des surplus on pense les épuiser
mais est ce qu'on pense pas qu'on a on
va se créer d'autres surplus en ajoutant
comme ça de l'éolien du solaire
non parce que
gal j'te maintenant le provisionnement
qui étaient déposés qui donne des
perspectives 2026 et 2027 avec le père
et avec l'électrification des transports
ont dit on a des besoins et 2026 et 2027
ces besoins ne peut pas attendre d'être
rendu à 2026 on doit commencer
aujourd'hui à y travailler mais
clairement on aura besoin d'énergie et
de puissance supplémentaire dans quatre
cinq six ans le soleil on aime ça quand
ils brillent fort et longtemps chez nous
qu'on a des beaux étés mais il brille
parfois plus fort et plus longtemps en
bien des endroits dans le monde quand on
regarde un peu la disposition de
l'insolation
on n'est pas des plus privilégiés la tue
pourquoi on met de l'énergie si vous me
permettez sur le développement de cette
filière là alors qu'on est déjà des
champions sur l'hydroélectricité qu'on
est déjà bon là dedans on fait de la
complémentarité comme je le mentionne
c'est le coût marginal on a besoin de
plus d'énergie plus de puissance le coût
marginal de l'éolien ou du solaire une
occupe suffit lyon est moins dispendieux
ils seront moins dispendieux
éventuellement de manière nette avec
l'hydroélectricité encore l'allemagne
premier pays européen en termes de
panneaux solaire et d'énergie solaire
qu'on regarde ce qu'on est au québec on
se compare avantageusement en termes de
l'ensoleillement avec l'allemagne dont
un hutois parfait merci on verra on va
suivre ça de près c'est toujours très
intéressant
merci monsieur le ministre d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir fera plaisir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici et redit
oh